foreign
aspect of human life has become
drugified in some way or another what do
I mean by drugified I mean made more
reinforcing releases more dopamine in
our brain's reward pathway made more
ubiquitous easier to access meaning that
24 7 we can get cupcakes cocaine and
pornography whenever we want so
therefore because our ancient wiring is
mismatched for this modern ecosystem we
now have a new mandate a new and
unprecedented mandate where we have to
intentionally insulate ourselves from
these reinforcing stimuli in order to be
in balance with our ancient wiring with
our bodies with this ecosystem and if we
don't do that if we relentlessly pursue
pleasure at it as it seems we are doing
now especially in Rich Nations we will
end up in this dopamine deficit state
which is our neurological response in
the process of becoming addicted and we
will end up more depressed more anxious
and overall less happy with our lives do
the data really show
that
cases are increasing
it's complicated and most most
psychologists and psychiatrists will
agree and that is the additional numbers
could be owed to a variety of things and
we know for example that during coven
cases Rose and that was mostly due most
psychiatrists show
to extreme loneliness and also when
people lost their jobs that produced
um concern anxiety worry depression the
second part of the story is that it's
become culturally acceptable to say that
you're depressed in fact amongst
high-income Americans it's become a
cultural necessity
so I'm told uh to have it therapist to
go on Facebook and talk about your
therapy and talk about your mentee B
which I discovered means mental
breakdown
the final thing is that when I looked at
the date
from the most recent data from Johns
Hopkins which was an excellent survey of
24 000 people but also the data from the
previous NIH survey of depression and
and both uh most recent Gallup polls it
does not show
that high income people are more
depressed than low-income people okay
those show the reverse yeah so when you
talk about the pla the pleasure paradox
maybe it ain't even there what I think
is compelling about uh the happiness
surveys which they've evolved to over
time is that they are purely subjective
so they have you on a ladder or a scale
from one to ten just rate how happy you
are and then they do that repeatedly
over years and it's not based on
individuals Patricia it's based on
Nations so if you're looking at data on
whether like individual wealthy people
feel better than individual you know
poorer people these data the happiness
surveys are based in aggregate on
countries and my claim being that a very
interesting Trend with happiness surveys
was that prior to about 2000 as wealth
increased in a given Nation happiness
went up but starting about 20 years ago
uh in those same countries uh happiness
started to go down and so I really do
think it does beg the question even if
especially since it's purely subjective
what is happening there what's the
phenomenon what are you saying why is
has the uh depression increased over the
last 20 years what is your point I
believe that
theater to Rising great
s of suicide in some countries uh is
over abundance and is our escalating
consumption of Highly reinforcing
substances and behaviors and the
drugification of everything that's more
of the last 20 years before that and by
the way when I say that I'm not saying
that mental illness is not a contributor
I'm not saying that trauma is not a
contributor I'm not saying that social
dislocation is not a contributor what
I'm asking people to contemplate is
whether or not it is our Relentless
pursuit of pleasure in all these
different forms that is actually
contributing to our misery and I'm
basing that on some inferences I'm
making on the Neuroscience which do show
that repeated consumption of Highly
reinforcing drugs and behaviors leads to
a dopamine deficit State and that's been
well documented that the pathophysiology
of addiction is that intoxicants release
a lot of dopamine all at once but over
time with repeated exposure you end up
in a dopamine chronic dopamine deficit
date which is our brains attempt to
compensate with this for this fire hose
of too many reinforcers and then you
essentially change your hedonic set
point and this is true whether the drug
is food and we're looking at obesity the
reason that obese people have so much
trouble losing weight is because they've
essentially changed their hedonic set
point and they have a great deal of
difficulty then changing that back
especially in an ecosystem where Salt
Fat sugar and flavorance have been added
to even sliced bread and on and on from
there with almost everything that we do
the difficulties still with these claims
that cases of depression are going up
amongst wealthy people we don't know why
I mean what are the things that I
realize as a scientist is that if you're
going to believe the data it's kind of
like buying a car a used car you really
got to do the work and look at it and
see whether or not you want to buy this
thing
and when you look at the data and Anna
admits this the data are based on
subjective reports
and we don't know whether there have
been cultural shifts
that largely or perhaps not at all we
just don't know whether there have been
cultural shifts that allow people or
even encourage people to say they're
depressed certainly in my farming
Community nobody was depressed I mean
nobody ever would admit to me
so so before we get on this bandwagon
about how people are this and people are
that they're having too much fun and
they really need their drugifying when
they go and visit their grandparents or
their grandchildren you know I have a
lot of fun when I'm just my
grandchildren am I being drugified
yeah I better go drop something hard on
my foot
in short this is the Dark Side of
capitalism it's a great system for human
achievement for Will To Power but there
is a dark side and we are entering that
dark side and that dark side is uh the
problem of overabundance over
consumption can I just say one quick
thing
correlation does not imply causality so
yes income has gone up that does not
imply that that's the cause of the
anxiety and depression it does not of
course but but
we can make causal inferences and that
the comment that you need quote unquote
real data is just to me that's kind of a
cop-out it's like the the kinds of data
that we need to answer these very
complex social psychological problems
are probably not within the scientific
method so we need to know
okay I got it this isn't a scientific
question then what the cause is
what matters is the cause at the end of
the day you're not not what the data
tells you what caused it and and if you
can't answer the cause to science what
can you method for Neuroscience as
opposed to social science it just
not what I said but I think that you
know the kinds of sort of looking at
Excel spreadsheets and you know looking
for the real facts and the numbers and
this and that if we only we just wait
for that then these problems that are
pressing social problems are going to
pass Us by if you just sit around and
wait for no no nobody's suggesting you
sit around and wait but it is a
scientific question and we would like to
get to the bottom of it for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institutes of awesome ideas
III TV